bonsoir Michel Jean Mireille
c'est bien d'être aussi sur la musique
de Vivement Dimanche non
tout de suite je vous propose que l'on
regarde à petit rappel de votre très
très long carrière je dis bien petit
parce que sinon ça serait justement
beaucoup trop long voilà
trace de rouge à lèvres voilà que je
vous ai posé sur votre jour oui mais
vous allez faire toutes les missions
avec on regarde quoi
monsieur
Drucker a reçu toutes les stars sans
exception sur son plateau
nombre d'entre elles sont devenus ses
amis il a grandi avec elle et devenu le
monsieur variété française de la
télévision il a reçu 56 fois de Johnny
Hallyday 52 fois Mireille Mathieu 51
fois Michel Sardou et c'est cette
fidélité qui séduit à l'insouchon on a
tellement l'habitude de le voir depuis
tellement longtemps moi j'aime que les
choses dures j'aime bien que les choses
restent un petit peu comme elles sont
enfin dans certains domaines et lui il
est celui qui est là depuis toujours il
a un côté paternel gentil bienveillance
le dernier des grands le dernier des
Mohicans c'est une légende vivante ça
bienveillance avec ses invités c'est
justement ce que certains lui reprochent
mais ceux qui le connaissent le mieux
ont une autre explication quelqu'un qui
a choisi de plus parler des gens qu'il
aime que les gens qui n'aiment pas
mais pas parce que c'est pas parce qu'on
parle des gens qu'on aime à la
télévision que qu'on aime tout le monde
c'est
de votre consécration pour Michel
Drucker depuis 10 ans son émission du
dimanche est devenu un rendez-vous
incontournable des politiques
il va même jusqu'à leur souhaiter leur
anniversaire
gâteau et cadeaux compris tout à fait
mignon voilà c'est un bichon frisé de
sexuumo n'est plus là pour des raisons
qu'on connaît j'ai pensé que ça vous
ferait plaisir
alors qui n'avez-vous pas reçu dans
votre émission le pape parce qu'il est
en tournée en permanence j'ai reçu
beaucoup de gens mais si j'aurais voulu
recevoir Mandela
genre le général de Gaulle que j'ai
croisé à l'Élysée mais j'étais trop
petit et j'étais trop jeune et inconnu à
l'époque mais j'aurais bien aimé être
nouvelle génération
qui s'adresse à votre frère disparu en
2003 votre frère est né Jean vous
racontez en plein de d'anecdotes aussi
ah c'est son les coulisses finalement de
la
très importante en 2002 pour eux et pour
moi avec Bernadette Chirac six mois
avant la présidentielle et puis j'ai
fait un tête-à-tête d'une heure voilà
qui reste un souvenir ce fameux tête à
tête au cours duquel vous lui avez
offert donc ce fameux bichon le bichon
regarde merci monsieur le Président
merci pour vous asseoir avec ce chien
voilà et je voudrais vous dire merci
encore votre livre de mémoire est un
succès considérable ça vous fait
évidemment très plaisir oui ça me fait
très plaisir oui est-ce que vous avez
commencé le deuxième tome oui mais
première chose en son temps je prends
mon temps je vous remercie beaucoup
Jacques Chirac le journal dans un
instant Vivement Dimanche prochain merci
vous dites qu'à partir du moment vous
lui avez offert d'ailleurs ce bichon il
ne vous écoutez plus l'interview était
fini
et dès qu'on a offert ce chien
l'émission n'est pas terminée il était
ailleurs il était ailleurs il a caressé
ce chien plus rien ne comptait pour cet
homme qui est quand même maintenant dans
la dernière partie de sa vie qui a
quitté la politique après 50 ans de
stress et ce chien était très important
pour lui parce qu'il avait été très très
blessé de de cette séparation avec le
précédent bichon qui n'avait pas
supporté le départ de l'Élysée donc
c'était subitement c'était typiquement
un enfant avec un petit animal c'est
très touchant et vous vous avez regretté
d'avoir eu cette idée là qui vous a été
un peu reproché d'ailleurs on s'est dit
pourquoi ce cadeau là
c'était une minute sur une heure à la
fin je dis MERCI pour résident il
caresse le chien la semaine prochaine
nous recevrons Charles Aznavour j'aime
beaucoup Charles Aznavour mais il était
ailleurs
il était ailleurs mais c'était très
émouvant oui alors justement sur la
famille Chirac vous dites que vous êtes
très lié à Jacques et Bernadette Chirac
quelqu'un de tout à fait extraordinaire
lorsqu'il y a plus les caméras il est
d'une grande drôlerie et Madame Chirac
un humour dévastateur et puis ils
adorent évidemment que je le raconte mes
émissions avec Giscard parce que nul
n'ignore que Giscard et Chirac c'est pas
l'entendre cordial depuis longtemps et
ce il s'aiment pas beaucoup pour des
raisons anciennes et politiques et ils
adorent que je leur raconte Giscard et
surtout l'émission le tête à tête avec
Jacques Chirac est passé à 19h dans
Vivement Dimanche prochain mais
l'après-midi j'avais fait une émission
sur les octogénaires on avait dit ils
ont quatre fois 20 ans et dedans il y
avait Giscard et c'est le hasard donc
Giscard ne comprenait pas pourquoi
Chirac était en vedette à 19h et lui oui
mais Chirac venait pour ses mémoires et
Giscard venait pour une émission qui
réunissait tous ceux qui a 80 ans sont
en pleine possession de leurs moyens il
y avait du mal à comprendre et
finalement il a fallu lui dire mais
voilà la fessée mémoires et toute façon
il est plus jeune que vous puisque
Chirac n'a pas encore 80 ans fan des
politiques vous Michel ou pas
intrigué
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'à 16 ans on a
envie de venir présent dans la
République qu'est-ce qu'elle est le son
qui coule dans leur veine alors il y a
que des coups à prendre c'est ça qui
vous fascine chez eux parce qu'il vous
fascine pour faire nos métiers et à plus
forte métier la politique il faut avoir
une résistance
de crocodiles il faut être un monde il
faut vraiment mental très fort
je pense que pour durer dans nos métiers
mais j'en parle beaucoup avec Johnny
j'en parle beaucoup avec Aznavour
puisque tous les gens dont je parle dans
le livre et que je raconte à Jean ils
ont tous un point commun Johnny s'est
fait insulter quand il était gamin
Aznavour je le dis aussi souvent traîné
dans la boue et bien non ils sont là ils
se sont inscrits dans la durée ce que
vous allez me dire
50 carrière de long tous en réussissent
sur la durée et réussir sur la durée
c'est une vraie gestion de son mental de
sa vie il faut savoir gérer sa santé il
faut savoir
dissimuler ses sentiments il faut savoir
encaisser des des humiliations il faut
savoir tourner ça en dérision il faut
savoir un livre les deux savoir il faut
savoir en rire plutôt que d'emploier
parfois il faut être très costaud car
c'est le stress qui est le grand danger
de nos métiers et des politiques
alors vous l'avez dit votre modèle ce
n'est pas un politique ce n'est pas un
artiste c'est votre frère aîné
mon frère est mort d'une crise d'Inde un
progostas très violent avec un arrêt
cardiaque
l'asthme c'est la maladie de l'anxiété
c'est la maladie du doute ces maladies
du mal d'être toujours été toujours
idole on l'a toujours été gamin dans la
ville de Vire il était le la star de la
ville il a toujours été la star partout
il est passé même si sans rendait pas
compte
il ressemblait à la fois Anthony Perkins
c'est à Jean-Claude brielly brun
intelligent élégant oui j'ai rêvé il
était le premier de la classe en plus
alors
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]